[Musik]
hallo meine lieben heute gibt es eine
richtig hübsche und leckere torte wir
machen einen schoko naked mit einer
leckeren sahne creme und frischen
früchten also für mich perfekte
komponenten vereint so ich zeig euch
jetzt zuallererst einen sehr speziellen
schokoladen boden ich lieg auch direkt
los die zutaten habe ich hier bereit
stehen und ihr könnt die ganz genauen
mengenangaben unten in der video
beschreibung nachlesen jetzt arbeite ich
heute mit meiner küchenmaschine aber ihr
könnt auch wie immer andere gerät
verwenden und jetzt nicht mit
zuallererst mein eiweiß wichtig ist dass
ihr das sauber trennt da sollten keine
eigelb reste mehr drin sein die gebe ich
jetzt hier einmal in meine rührschüssel
gibt es die hälfte des zuckers mit hinzu
und dann schlage ich das so ungefähr
vier minuten lang richtig schön stress
kann euch auch helfen wenn ihr erstmal
ohne zucker anfing zu schlagen und dann
nach und nach den zucker einrieseln
lassen
[Musik]
und entstanden ist eine schöne feste
masse die gebe ich ganz kurz an die
seite habe jetzt eine neue röhre schüsse
auf die küchenmaschine gesetzt und jetzt
nämlich meinen rühe haken das finde ich
immer am besten geeignet wenn man butter
cremig schlagen möchte so da gebe ich
jetzt die batterien die sollte
bestenfalls zimmer warm sein nicht zu
kalt aus dem kühlschrank kommt jetzt die
restliche der restlichen zucker mit dazu
und dann schlagen wir das so ungefähr
vier minuten und ihr werdet merken dass
die butter richtig schön hell cremig
sein wird
[Musik]
im nächsten schritt wollen wir schon mal
die eigelbe ein und ich mache es auch
immer so dass ich die trockenen zutaten
nämlich mit speisestärke bei kakao und
backpulver vorab miteinander verrühren
denn jetzt kommen die trockenen zutaten
einmal in die butter eigelb masse aber
ganz ganz wichtig ich habe ja auch noch
ein bisschen milch und wir geben das
immer abwechselnd hinein also nicht erst
die trockenen zutaten und dann nehme ich
uns haben wir klümpchen und wenn ihr
alle schritte beachtet dann habt ihr
später einen richtig schönen saftigen
schoko teig
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir hier die fertige butter
masse und die b c max ist es ganz
wichtig dass wir die b&c masse in zwei
bis drei schritten am besten mit einem
teig schaber unterheben
mit ganz viel liebe
[Musik]
meine schokoladen tag ist jetzt fast
fertig ist kommt noch einen zutat mit
hinzu und zwar nehme ich heute die
double shot waffeln von lorca und ich
bin ganz ehrlich ich bin total froh über
die zusammenarbeit denn ihr wisst ja ich
gucke immer auch so auf dem background
der firmen und locker das ist eben ein
familienunternehmen aus südtirol und ich
habe mir mal die zutatenliste hinten
auch durchgelesen und hier steht bonbon
vanilleschote das heißt kein künstliches
vanillin erkenntnis mittlerweile also
ich bin ja gar kein fan von künstlicher
vanille und wenn ihr da auf hochwertige
zutaten achten möchte dann lege ich euch
das jetzt gerade sehr ans herz und das
mache ich folgendes ich packe mir zwei
packungen aus und wird erst mal klein
schneiden und dann hieß nochmal unter
den teig
[Musik]
als nächstes folgt er den teig in eine
20 cm springform die ihr mit backpapier
ausgekleidet und der doppelschock boden
wird jetzt bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze im vorgeheizten backofen bei
45 bis maximal 48 minuten gebacken und
anschließend dass ich ihn vollständig
auskühlen bis gleich
so weiter geht mein boden kühlt gerade
ab und ich nutze die zwischenzeit und
mache jetzt meine klassische sahne creme
spät habe im auftragen werde ich die
kämen aber noch mit roter grütze
verfeinern jetzt erst mal zur creme
wichtig ist ihr kennt das schon von mir
alle zutaten sollen kalt sein ich hab
sogar gerade die schüssel und den
aufsatz einmal für fünf minuten in den
kühlschrank getan das hilft enorm glaubt
mir so und jetzt gebe ich alle zutaten
rein wie gesagt ihr findet sie und
myvideo beschreibung ich starte mit
frischkäse das ist doppel rahm
frischkäse nimmt nicht die fettarme
variante gebe ich direkt in die schüssel
da kommt nochmals capone dazu sahne
butter zucker und vanille extrakt und
dann fange ich anders zu rühren und gibt
dann nach und nach seine fest dazu
[Musik]
und unsere creme ist fertig als nächstes
werde ich den boden durchschneiden und
zwar zweimal so dass wir drei bühnen
erhalten
[Musik]
so ein wenig ganz oben angelangt seid
dann lasst eure kreativität freien lauf
ich habe mich jetzt hier das könnte man
es nennen mag habe ich jetzt viel muster
entschieden das sieht so ein bisschen
aus wie eine blume von oben schaut
jo und jetzt möchte ich die hat optisch
auch noch ein bisschen aufpimpen mit
frischen früchten und natürlich den
double cork warfen damit man auch weiß
was in ihnen steckt
[Musik]
dollar fertig ist unser naked cache ich
persönlich finde dass jetzt jeder aus
der familie eine komponente mindestens
hat die am markt wir haben schokolade
wir haben die sahne creme wir haben
früchte wie haben vanille wir haben
eigentlich alles also ganz schnell
nachmachen und mir eure fotos zu
schicken noch besser postet sie mit dem
hashtag iges kitchen und täglich darauf
instagram weil ich freue mich immer wenn
ich eure kreationen sehen und sie dann
auch wie posten kann ansonsten wie
gesagt alle ganz genauen informationen
hier unten in der video beschreibung
hinterlässt die sind video auf jeden
fall ein bäumchen nach oben und ein
kostenloses abo damit ihr auch solch
genialen rezepte nicht mehr verpassen
probiert sie unbedingt aus die zergehen
richtig im mund und ja ansonsten freue
ich mich wenn ihr bei meinem nächsten
video auch wieder dabei sein kiki
[Musik]